[MUSIC PLAYING]
BENJAMIN TREYNOR
SLOSS: What is SRE?
Well, SRE has become a lot of
things over the past 15 years.
But when we started it in 2004,
it was a pretty simple concept.
It's what you get when
you treat operations
as a software problem
and you staff it
with software engineers.
And everything else
came from that.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
SRE is a way of thinking
and approaching production.
It's a set of principles
and practices.
And so in a sense,
most people who
are engineers who could
be developing a system
can also be an SRE working
on that same system.
And when we talk to
somebody about joining SRE,
we're really looking
for a few things.
First of all, do they
have a natural tendency
to avoid toil and want to
automate it away and make
a computer do it?
If they're allergic to doing
things by hand over and over
again, and if they
have the computer
skills to take the work that
they've been doing by hand
and make a computer
do it instead,
they got a good
character trait for SRE.
Secondly, can they
handle complexity?
And in particular, can
they take a complex
and maybe not
well-defined problem
and come up with a scalable,
technically reasonable solution
for it and implement
that solution?
We call those skills
non-abstract large systems
design.
And it's a skill that
pretty much every SRE
uses every single day.
Finally, we look for
an innate curiosity
about how things work.
We're looking for people
who will learn over
the course of their
lifetime in SRE
and understand systems as they
develop and as they change.
When we find someone
with those attributes,
we have someone
with the potential
to be a really excellent SRE.
JENNIFER PETOFF: So
once we find someone
who generally fits
that shape, that's
when the real work begins.
When it comes to
SRE, there's a lot
to learn, from reliability best
practices and design patterns,
to the ins and outs of
complex production systems,
to incident management
best practices and more.
Over the years, we've developed
hundreds of hours and thousands
of pages of material to help
develop those inclinations
into excellent
production skills.
Once someone gets up to speed
on an SRE team at Google,
then we spend a lot of effort
on continuing education,
things like rotations
and short-term projects.
Great SREs aren't hired,
they're actually trained.
And their skills
are honed over time.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
BENJAMIN LUTCH: Google
was a lot smaller than it
is today when we started SRE.
In the beginning, SRE was just a
few people in a couple offices.
Today, we're more than 2,500
folks spread around the world.
Basic SRE principles scale
from very small to super large.
As long as you keep
them in mind and let
them guide you along
the way, you'll
end up in the right place.
If I were starting another
company from scratch again,
I would definitely be
doing SRE from day one.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
BETSY BEYER: For a long
time, we wouldn't talk
about SRE outside of Google.
It was the secret sauce.
But a few years ago, we
started to rethink that.
Now we spend a lot
of time working
to build a large and
vibrant SRE community.
We've published
several books and also
dozens of articles,
videos, and trainings,
with much more to come.
Almost all of this material
is available for free
on Google SRE's home page.
We know that an important
part of SRE's value
is creating something
meaningful and lasting
for a larger community.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
BENJAMIN TREYNOR
SLOSS: Well, that's
the uncomfortably exciting part.
I have a lot of
ideas, but the truth
is I don't really
know for certain.
Now that SRE has grown to be
a global community and not
just a Google thing, the
future of the profession
is determined by the progress
and innovations of everyone
in SRE.
And if you had asked
me in 2004 what
would become of the SRE team, I
would not have predicted this.
I thought it was going
to be a very small niche
part of computer science.
So what I do predict
is that the community
of smart and motivated people
who now make up the global SRE
teams will continue to
come up with new ideas.
They'll continue to innovate.
They'll continue to advance
the state of the art
and advance what is possible.
And I'll be part of that,
but just part of it.
So really, I'm looking forward
to seeing what you all create.
[MUSIC PLAYING]